a lot of people have asked me how many  concussions have you had and I'm like I  don't know I've had like two or three  that I had like symptoms from I also hit  the wall probably 60 70 80 times I don't  know I hit the wall a lot I raced for 27  years I crashed in go-karts I crashed in  race cars what is it that actually  deems an impact to concussion well  technically it's when you have when  you're symptomatic really but the  question is what does more damage the  big hits or the little hits Joe Lewis  actually said it best a famous  heavyweight champion boxer it's not the  big hits that cause dementia it's the  thousands of little hits and so if you  think of Navy SEALs for example they do  thousands of breaching exercises where  they're blowing up things that is a  sub-concussive blow so what happens in a  concussion well the brain starts to  swell